sur du pain 12 elle tu fais plus jamais
ça y est on sait ce pays aujourd'hui on
se tourne pour le quest ix antam 12
on est à l'heure comme d'habitude un nom
comments est parti voir voilà la
question et si tu te laisser pousser les
cheveux ça ferait peut être un style non
non non non non créer un dîner entre
john boye vie soit pas jaloux je ne suis
pas jaloux je m'en fous totalement
effondré via j'étais mon bébé je veux te
faire l'amour
quel et les fugues et c'est le râteau
pourrait vite on est vraiment triste
très attristé sûr qu'elle va se
rabattent sais tu que tu es un
illuminati je pensais l'avoir toujours
très bien caché grâce à ma coupe de
cheveux nul à temps mais tu es notre
chef d'atos c'est un beau discours pour
nous d abonnés c'est vrai que j'ai
jamais fait de beaux discours pour vous
et je pense qu'il ya un début à tout
chers abonnés je suis aujourd'hui si
pour vous remercier car je peux vivre de
ma passion grâce à vous j'exerce tout ça
dans la plus grande des passions le mot
d'ordre chez moi c'est le plaisir avant
tout la passion tout le reste tout le
reste je m'en tape ainsi jean rend
l'argent aux abonnés ce qui
éventuellement on peut tout oublié t'es
au courant qu'on a un dossier sur ton
escale en afrique maintenant je sais
pourquoi mais c'était vraiment très beau
voyage et vous le faites pleurer dit les
choses comme ça tu m'auras pas tous
d'accord c'est bien que la seule chirac
à qui j'ai des yeux pour ou la virginité
si tu devais sauver une personne sur est
plutôt guen jumbo vous vous doutez bien
une réponse enfin
donne moi ton fric
jumbo pourquoi tu as pris tant de temps
pour sortir le questionne le précieux
quoi mais adobe justement la question
disparaît mais c'est quoi ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle quelle est ta réaction
face au bout non vous ouvrant à bonn
toiture ans j'ai ma chambre fait la
scène du roi lion avec jumbo écoute je
pense qu'il sera meilleur acteur que
simba
l'homme à lunettes la langue du mal et
jumbo n'ont ils pas à lier un mystique
que tu ne dévoile pas comment tu sais
peu de temps après avoir enfermé la
lampe et pervers dans la salle de bain
je me rendais de mon bureau et j'ai
entendu des bruits suspects venant de
cette dernière
je décide alors d'ouvrir la porte et
c'est là que le fruit du démon était né
c'est la véritable histoire de 10
chevaux
on comprend maintenant pourquoi il tout
le temps blasé regarder ses parents
franchement la toile être un accord un
enfant avec sweetie a très longtemps
en fait j'ai très peur qu'au moment de
la naissance ça se passe comme ça où est
passé de talons que le psychopathe tu as
enfin réussi à temps débarrassé belge il
avait enfermé dans la salle de bain à la
fin du coût total précédent le pervers
s'étaient échappés avaient tué la reine
de la farine
paix à son âme mais la lampe est
toujours enfermé dans la salle de bains
est la légende dit que si on fait un
petit silence on peut l'entendre
la légende est faussée pris 1,9 à la
menthe nous dit tu seras le prochain
mois à bajaur s'être enfermé dans la
salle de bain tu sais que ce phoque
s'échapper
malena rembe la prophétie se réalise qu
est le moment le plus gênantes à vie
alors je me souviens que dans le plus
récent arrêtent des autres mon cerveau
les efface automatiquement voilà système
d'autodéfense jetait une soirée avec des
potes et il y en a une qui s'appelle
isabelle et bon elle s'appelle pas
isabelle sinon alors à 45 ans elle a 45
ans mais isabelle boulay pechoux un mec
que j'ai vu embrasser une autre fille et
du coup je dédie à mes amis qui m'ont
dit de ne surtout pas le répéter à
isabelle un peu plus tard dans la soirée
on se trouve en petit comité moi mes
amis et zabelle c'est quand ça finit
recherchez vous avez et isabelle dit non
mais de façon ça me fait un qui soit
proche qu'ils soient ensemble tout lui
est là je réponds quoi comme un gros con
doivent être faits par les abeilles
c'est bien ce qu un bisou ça veut rien
dire sur ce coup c'est celle où il t'a
fait toujours du savon alors pour la
petite histoire et vient de perdre ses
lunettes ce qui fait qu'il est
complètement à côté de la plaque ne faut
pas lui dire mon chat est mort
j'aimerais qu'on pose des questions
ayant la forme de h r on n'est pas là
pour pleurer [ __ ] mais voilà c'est
trop tard il ya un fait dans son
appartement tu sauves qu'ils ont à jumbo
guen ou talent et coup la question ne se
pose pas mal an elle va se faire et les
autres bas les enfants et aux [ __ ]
mais ce que je sais pas lors d'un petit
barbecue party allez je vous propose un
petit barbecue en toute cordialité
si tu mets mais c'est déjà pour trouver
son style mais je suis garde
c'est à toi tu que je te le thème numéro
12 g faire ça nous a plu si ces cas
n'hésitez pas à faire découvrir autrui a
aimé la vidéo bien sûr vous vous en
doutez on se sent très bien dans une
prochaine vidéo personnes ont regardé
les catalans de pics